we must show with the Wiis right now
immediately immediately Paulie sure he's
promoting he's gonna podcast call Pauly
Shores random rants and he's also got a
bunch of gigs Thursday through Sunday
Carolinas and probably want to come in
why is don't be scared
it's your safe you he's saying it the
East Coast versus West Coast this is
like the old school hip-hop beat yeah
[Laughter]
thank you very much it's good to have a
healthy paranoia everywhere that you go
you just never know do you
see the bell of honor he's ringing it
for himself
yeah it's a great Bell the fans love it
it's a new feature they've really taken
to it yeah did you think that of all the
radio shows you'd be doing this would be
the one that would still have a cowbell
in studio for you you know I've always
been a fan of the cowbell really me yeah
because it's like it's a call to action
you know people respond to it you can't
ignore it no it's like hey we're here
it's like even like you know people are
like you're at a deli you know and I
mean you want to grab a ticket you know
like food hey we're here yeah you always
you're always worried they're gonna know
you're not gonna hear your number
getting called yeah cowbell is what if
they do a cowbell before every number
you're gonna hear every number
yeah do you use it or is it just sitting
there I use it it's Jim's Bell of honor
that he brings yes yeah I ring it
sometimes all the times just to make the
wait listeners up but just attention for
myself right
sometimes if Sam's talkie I'll just
interrupt like that and everybody looks
at me can I say something or if you
don't have any jokes you could just ring
the bell thanks for having me guys
thanks for being here Paula sure we're
on this is life yeah yeah we'll do it
will get better in Josh okay okay all
right all right our guest this morning
or be what a great guest all I'm gonna
get to the credit check
yeah
you know if you seen Encino man if you
had MTV from 1989 to 1994 he was a VJ I
mean he hosted Spring Breaks the man has
[ __ ] a lot of attractive girls please
our guest today and some really handsome
guys some really attractive girls did
you [ __ ] Chris Cuomo know that Fredo is
an ethnic slur I didn't know that I
didn't hear almost said it's equivalent
to the n-word yeah that's that's the
word well yeah yeah I liked his video I
thought that was cool I'm winding him
snapping yeah that's who he really is
yeah which is cool yes nothing wrong
with that he's like you know he said if
you watch him host his show on CNN he
always looks like he's gonna snap Ray's
got a big neck with all the veins
bulging out of blacks he's I don't
understand why he always wears a black
jacket look I know it's not a good look
it's like that's for the Oscars that's
true you know what I mean it's like not
wowing
but that's more it's like a funeral the
Oscars this is not you know let me mix
it up I don't know why maybe yeah maybe
a pinstripe or a dark blue suit yeah he
should even a great something different
but I like that he's snap because that's
who that's who the guy is
have you ever snapped in public I mean
I'm sure you got people coming up to you
all the time with some dumb [ __ ] man I
don't know if ever a snap before I
probably have have as a fan of a push
you to snap some of my assistants have
yeah why it's hard it's never had one I
mean I Kenny doesn't work three B's on
the system he just needs a road manager
but no I've never had one it's tough
assistant so that like the systems are
really hard to come by how leave me good
assistant a good assistant what's a
common thing that you'll go like out
[ __ ] another bad one well most of them
don't want to be there do you understand
I'm like most assistants do not want to
be there you know most assistants they
don't want to be assisting right so you
could feel the energy right you're
working with them it's not like when
you're coming up with stuff say hey
let's do this look you could feel like a
resistance you know because they're
pretty
much like composing emails and doing
attachments and scanning and assisting
you what's worse than booking [ __ ]
fly
it's a nightmare and I want my flights
Kenny does and he's [ __ ] knows more
about the flights and the airlines do he
there's no one will ever be number he's
the best I got he is Joey you sense a
resentment like you're resistant so you
don't know it's almost like you know
being [ __ ] in the ass people don't
like that
yeah but Rhys drawn you learn to accept
anything it's not but why do they sign
up I there needs to be a website called
I really want to be an assistant because
it's not a job it's not a job that that
most people you know so why are they
signing up are you finding these people
why are they signing up to be your
assistant they don't want to do it to
start with
or are you too demanding I think it's a
combo hmm you know how long does it
usually take you to realize this is a
mistake
well no the thing is it's like with me
it's like I am a certain way and
everyone thinks that I'm a certain way
but then when you start working with me
I'm not that way
now you want flaky or flighty and then
they're like no this is business
like really like organized and anal and
almost you know what you want yeah all
my stuff and but I think like I mean
you've heard of the old school like
assistance for like how old Hollywood
like they've been there for years
yeah and they're cool with it those are
the type of people that are cool with it
but because I mean I was even talking to
I don't mention names but someone who's
very prestigious in the music business
Jeffrey Epstein no I think you are Kelly
oh and he was just telling me how hard
it is to get employed employers these
days to do things employers well people
that work under because please employees
yeah because people are so like all over
the place are you good at firing
somebody I think it's almost like
breaking up with a chick you know you it
kind of it's building right and then I
you know
like have you ever you know been with a
chick that you've been with for a while
and then you know that you're not
supposed to be with them and then you're
like one [ __ ] how am I gonna do this so
it just kind of builds and their fear
they feel it do the assistant feels it
too but a couple of I mean years ago one
of your I guess it was an intern or an
ex assistant whoever they were wrote
this like article for vice talking about
how much it sucked working for Pauly
Shore and I'm like reading the article
and I'm going like it's just there's
nothing it's supposed to be this
tell-all piece and it's just regular
work that you would think an assistant I
do like I was mad cuz I had him carry my
merch bag up the stairs to the Comedy
Store but links in my office and the
third job just one of his things like
you know I can't carry it you know what
I mean so it's like it's a big merch bag
you know I mean you know you go on the
road you got it
give the merch out Southern merch
whatever but why do you have a person
and then you carry your own [ __ ] and
you're paying the person like the person
you're paying can carry the [ __ ] yeah no
yeah I think it's just about paying your
dues I think oh yeah a lot of kids don't
want to do I mean if you look at it now
this society everyone's on the birds
everyone's got their office set up at
[ __ ] Starbucks mm-hmm you know people
are air being being an uber and [ __ ] is
everyone's kind of finding a way to
survive without actually [ __ ] having
a job right he's day-to-day you can get
by yeah a bird those [ __ ] little
scooters it costs nothing to get around
so you don't need a [ __ ] car I know
right yeah right need a car and then you
know if you want to set up your computer
you can work at Starbucks for free you
don't have an office right and then you
know if you need to go somewhere you can
go air B&B or if you need it air B&B you
know what I mean yeah I would never do
air B&B I might have done it once it
scares me these people's people I don't
be in somebody's [ __ ] space a hotel I
like better even though it's in the same
way but people live but I mean people
love air B&B especially people that
travel a lot they've knew some people
love staying in other people's houses
instead of hotels I don't
would you ever look at me I would
definitely stay in my [ __ ] nose no no
look at my [ __ ] no no I live air B&B
before I I don't mind it like when I
played the heat that the hyenas you know
how it is there's that in
room Texas I know oh dude you gotta do
it thanks Butler rookie there it's great
it's it's basically play know it's it's
Dallas and it's Fort Worth he's got
three rooms and they're awesome oh okay
yeah you play like a Friday you do play
no Saturday do Fort Worth Sunday or
whatever it's Dallas but you stay in one
hotel and you just kind of half-hour
drives
oh okay so yeah I'd kind of like that
it's yeah right but it's great he's
great you'd do great out there so what's
the what so what's your process did you
change up your process for how you hire
these people if the turnover is so
quicker or no I'm just at a place right
now where I don't need an assistant
right you do yourself no I have people
that temp that kind of come in that I've
been with me for a long time
I got a kid named Yousef I got my friend
Eric I got my friend Michael everyone's
got other gigs so I'll like book I'm Way
in advance and a lot of these guys you
know this guy Yousef he's a friend of
mine and also my assistant he also you
know drives around weed you know he's a
weed person delivery guy yeah so he does
that in the day that at night he'll come
in and we'll bang out some emails and
organize so but he doesn't resent the
work he does after two-three hours you
have to do certain hours like because
Lady Gaga's assistant suitor cuz she's
like ah she wanted me to work all these
hours at no overtime it's like how do
you establish an assistance hours I know
if you wake up in a weird hour and you
got thoughts at one night write this
email like what is the point right to
have having an assistant and so that you
have these thoughts and you're like yeah
I can now I can call I'm gonna hire this
thing I think the way I have it
organized now is the best which is you
just do an hourly thing and you have
like three or four own assistants and
they're all good at different things
okay I also have a social media girl
Beth Beth loops out of st. Louis that I
met actually when I did I did the st.
Louis funny bone
you have played that room no oh my god
another great room
it's the oldest funny bone in America
and it's a great room so I met her she
was doing the social media for the club
and then she does it for a couple comics
I'm like [ __ ] this chicks awesome and
then I got together with her and she
just says my social from st. Louis but
does she yeah
I have somebody who looks at certain
analytics and tells me good times but I
would never let me I don't like anybody
tweeting for me or no that's not that
it's mostly like photos and videos so
how's that and then like Flyers for
clubs right right right you didn't mean
like the ads in the multimedia stuff
yeah she's she's into it she's excited
so I have a pretty good team do you do
you obsess over ticket counts when
you're on the road well it's kind of
like one of those things like if the
club's not telling you anything then
you're not sold out yet right you named
me so then you know it's kind of like an
underlying you know thing you if you're
sold out they tell you what's worse than
when you walk in through the kitchen and
the first shows about to start or
whatever you're 10 minute and you can
hear like the little random chatter and
it's not the chatter of a full room like
you get your individual conversation
it's a smattering of people or you know
it's half-full and you can just hear it
the thing is with me like I don't mind
performing in front of half-full rooms
or rooms that are not sold out cuz
that's just God saying it's not sold out
it's like whatever yeah don't be another
sold-out show and there won't be a so it
doesn't hurt your ego no no I I just
like to go on stage yeah so it's like
[ __ ] obviously we once sold out shows
but it's also as a performer I think as
you know I think it's good performing
not in front of sold-out shows sometimes
your [ __ ] around more yeah you have a
little more freedom but I do that kind
of stuff at the cellar and I I don't
this ad we sold out but it's not me what
it's [ __ ] I did once in a while you do
want it's just like oh yeah and you're
like what I've been working all these
years for what for what do you ever
think that big when you when you see a
room like that or do you not really
worry too much about what like is it
with the way Jim goes like I've been
doing this all these years and still
this is what the room looks like or did
you just go this is tonight we'll see
what happens tomorrow as long as there's
other shows that are doing well that
weekend yeah she you know I mean cuz
everyone knows a Friday second shows the
worst yeah and everyone knows like a
Sunday shows okay and the Saturday show
first show sells out yeah sells out so
it's like whenever we're still making
money doing what we love yeah like at
the end of the day your checks not as
big but [ __ ] it you get to make people
laugh I mean I love
yeah the day that's what it's about it's
like you know you go up there and it's
just you know people are there to see
you and it's like what's better than
that yeah yeah were you like have you
always been like that or or was there a
period of time after movies where like I
got a transition after my parents died
yeah you might know that sure yeah my
mom and dad died and all that my sister
died I had all this like I just when you
when you have parents that died and
you're by yourself you just go [ __ ]
we're all not here forever period I got
then you all obviously people are
listening and you guys I don't know you
personally - well obviously but I assume
you have relatives and aunts and uncles
and cousins and people that have died
that's right it's [ __ ] up yeah I mean
it makes you just kind of like look at
life go [ __ ] you know like for me like
you know I just kind of say at the end
of every day I'm almost like God gave me
another day because think about how many
people died of cancer
oh my god yeah is it that you don't know
like people like get bring my friend
Gary died of brain cancer you know Gary
[ __ ] Gary Garfinkel I think I know
him Showtime didn't you do stuff at
Showtime no never no oh never Showtime
well he he was a friend that worked
there and he he got breaking my point is
is that the older you get I think the
more you realize like [ __ ] were not here
forever yeah I [ __ ] me up the other
day I was like we've been waiting on a
bill from an electrician that did work
in our house and my dad called and I'm
like you're that bill
you don't have to worry about that bill
I was like why not yeah you got colon
cancer and died all right yeah you plant
this okay his family well I don't think
the bill is gonna be coming you know
he's an old-school guy just head it down
in a notebook wasn't I don't know I
didn't get the bill okay well there's no
silver lining so what I'm saying is
sometimes it's good yeah I think you
know I'm 51 now so it's like you know I
got 30 more years left here is that what
you're counting on I mean if I'm lucky
right if you make it to 80 I want to
make it past then I'm 51 - I want to
make it past how many time at what with
your [ __ ] I don't social behavior I
don't sleep well but I eat okay I don't
drink I don't sighs
yeah yeah yeah I think that's important
have you always been I mean cuz you've
always been an inch ape guy have you
always had like I always yeah always
exercised yeah right yes I used to party
a lot Reggie so party they've never
really partied that hard really no it
wasn't no not like I never I always had
that saying it's okay to dance with the
devil don't become the devil I see
meaning cuz I grew up around all these
comedians that were getting [ __ ] up
and I always kind of knew like oh [ __ ]
those guys are at another level I guess
it goes one way or the other like you
were with Kennison like really early on
yes and he was [ __ ] partying a lot
right you don't mean but I also I'm a
Jewish kid from Beverly Hills okay so
it's like not saying that like that I
mean I'm a little neurotic you know I
mean like I'm not the kid I'm not the
guy from a small town that like all of a
sudden made it and you know like Oh
drugs drugs drugs drugs drugs right not
my whole life you know even growing up
when I was a kid like you know my
brother was best friends with Griffin
O'Neil Ryan O'Neal son Farrah Fawcett
and all that like back you know you know
Donovan leach and Mike Messick's and we
used to go to this club called The
Odyssey and and all these people this
was early Hollywood like kids were
[ __ ] getting [ __ ] up it's like less
than zero what did you say yeah I was I
don't know if you guys remember that
movie your Julianne gives good head and
is dead that was what they wrote on the
wall of our [ __ ] Robert Downey jr.
you do remember that me yeah I do
great Spader was great in that who's the
guy
the lead Andrew we played his name was
Andrew in the movie McCarthy yeah I mean
it's like that's how it was back then
you know what I mean in you know and I
had a lot of friends died of coke I had
my friend Brent Weinberger flipped it
Jeep because he was on quaaludes and
died oh my god yeah so early on you
figure out that that you know this leads
to bad places quick and also the fact is
I'm fortunate knock on wood I'm not I
don't have that that that I'm not a drug
addict meaning like or alcoholic ago if
I go out at the most I'll have his three
drinks even at your peak though cuz I
mean when we're waiting for you yeah you
know people wanted a
I mean I'm sure people still do but when
when the weasel was the weasel and you
were everywhere and how we say it around
here bro what is so right but when that
was everywhere right and when here in
every movie when you're every TV show
I'm sure everybody went people wanna
party I didn't stay out until the Sun
went up as your question is your answer
lady I did a couple of times but it
wasn't like a theme you have to be
disciplined then there's just not your
style when you grow up with a - it's
probably little different took it it's
not new I there's no adjustment to this
being new if that's your whole life
you'll say yeah see comics they do coke
and this is what it is yeah it's what
you see yeah I mean she liked it I liked
it right there was definitely some times
where I went crazy yeah but it wasn't
several times I see so tonight's the
crazy night and then just happen like
yeah yeah I mean Sam when we did what
was it it was the felt way it was that
Aladdin the Aladdin hotel it was me Sam
and Tommy Chong and it was uh it was New
Year's Eve and that was like a night I
remember it was that it was the night it
was the year before he passed on 1990 no
it was like ninety one night where he
died in 92 right yeah I don't remember
91 92 yeah those around there but um you
know that was like you know I was with
the porn star and it was like you know
what I mean yeah that was it was wild
yeah that's a fun time it was cool yeah
it was like it was fun yeah we had to
get tenders yeah I don't know if I've
asked you about your prior before I
think I have but I mean you know I never
knew him I met him once so I never any
kind of relationship with him but you
you knew him pretty well
yes yeah I knew him very well yeah and
if there's a couple of versions of him
there's the version that you see like
that you see the interview he did where
he's really [ __ ] up it's in Arizona of
course and he's like drunk and he's high
and he's being funny and he likes the
guy he's talking to but you can see he
was a difficult guy at times is that the
version of him you usually so never saw
that version you didn't ever know it saw
the really quiet sweet version he did
cuz every time he came to the store he
was always very quiet and sweet and in
in nice and polite because he was you
know they are to develop his his his you
know his his
so he would come in and kiss people's
hands and shake and you know and sit
down and and I would give him like a
Courvoisier and my mom would sit next to
him and the manager of the club would
would be like you know he was a sty guy
Ted you know is either Ted or Kirk and
they he would keep people away and then
he I would ask him when do you want to
go on he you know in but it was soft
you saw the quieter version yeah before
I go onstage when you blew up were other
comics shitty to you or do they like you
because they knew you from the time you
were young
I think it's that's a good question it's
kind of a combo I think you know I had
this thing with Chris Rock where me and
him when we first met in late 80s or
early the el8 80s like when I used to
come out here to do stand-up I would
perform at uh catch you know and that
was Sandler and Seinfeld and who else
[ __ ] I don't know they were all there
and and me and Chris bonded because and
then when he came out to LA we bonded to
at the store because he was Eddie
Murphy's boy and everyone was like oh
he's only because he's Eddie Murphy's
boy right and then for me it was all
like oh he's only because he's Mitzi's
kids right and that was like this thing
that we had you both had like something
attached to why you were doing well why
when people yeah yeah so yeah it's it is
what it is you know yeah it's like what
are you gonna do it's like you know but
I think you know thank God I kind of I
cut through it and I started all these
movies and people in the Middle America
they don't know my mom is they don't
know the commie stories totally
they just know you from MTV in the film
yeah they know me my comedy my MTV
podcasts whatever doing the things like
do you still do stuff too I know one
point you were doing stuff like slides
on stage I didn't see it but I just
remember thinking it was an interesting
idea to kind of you know do a show like
a one-man show built around yeah I was a
long time ago I did that I forgot what
part of my my act that was but yeah we
should do a slide show but yeah I'm
gonna start working on you know all that
stuff now I'm gonna put together a book
one-man show documentary all that's
were you with your monitor at the annual
weather yeah that's good yeah yeah for
15 years it's kind of easier not easier
but I'm sure it helps if you know
somebody is not well because at least
you get to be there your last moment
which was interesting you learn a lot on
hospice I've ever experienced putting
anyone down on Hospice no it's [ __ ]
wild how bad oh my god it's a whole
other [ __ ] world well do you have to
suggest this is crazy
why is that well first of all you know
the person's gonna pass right there's
not they're not gonna get better
this is your last stop this is your last
stop yeah do they know it - like when
you're bringing someone there do you
tell her that or does she go look I know
what this is or is there still like you
kind of keep it upbeat
I think people aren't stupid you know
even my dad he was on hospice and my mom
was on Hospice
I think that you know I mean especially
when people are leaning over you crying
and basically saying like hey yeah
they're stopping by their last vision
you know it was [ __ ] crazy dude was
my sister died this last year and I had
to say my goodbyes in a Hooters parking
lot in [ __ ] in flying why is that was
on the road you on the phone yeah it was
on the phone and it was with Sandy danto
you know sandy he's a comedian we are
we're at Hooters you know we were having
lunch and I don't know some small-town
huh and then the doctor calls and says
it's time I'm like [ __ ] but you knew she
was sick there was not sudden yeah yeah
she had been sick and I didn't know it
was gonna be that you know what I mean
so so they called me and then I'm pretty
much like crying in a Hooters parking
lot saying goodbye to my sister sandy eh
it's okay did you finish your lunch or
did you have to excuse yourself from
lunch going to the parking lot and then
come back in - yeah you had to go back
and finish after yeah that's tough what
do you say how do you say how do you
rant just kind of open up your heart and
you just say you know hey I mean it's
hard to remember cuz I was like in the
moment yeah you have any sauce in your
beard did you know I didn't hear back
then oh okay now it's just basically
saying like
hey everything's fine you're gonna
you're gonna be okay I love you so much
and you know [ __ ] I don't know what else
to say you did she had she talked her
she just listening no but but yeah just
listening but my point that I was I was
gonna say is that it's the last thing
that goes with people and I didn't know
this is [ __ ] hearing like even if a
person is like like that they could
still hear so if you have anything to
say they hear it just say wow cuz that's
what my point is that's what I heard
about the hospice you know that's when I
talk to the hospice nurse cuz you know
you don't know that you asked 50
thousand questions when's it gonna
happen I mean if you ask me anything
about that I could talk for hours about
just how the whole thing goes down it's
so wild isn't that what they said about
Patrice when he was in the hospital that
you have to be careful what you say it
was a sign on the door we went in Matt
and I went to see him this was after his
stroke yeah yeah there was a sign that
said mr. O'Neal may be able to hear you
yeah they weren't sure because it was a
stroke and he couldn't do anything but
yeah you can't react but he can maybe
still he commanded comas you said I
heard everything for 15 years a lot of
shit-talking I'm sure that's the thing
so anyone listening like if you're
putting anyone down in your family
members like any respectful in the room
and don't argue don't you know can hear
it they hear everything so well you it
was your mom coherent when you went in
like did she kind of know or was she
like was she able to communicate with
you there was no communication but you
can still feel that she was feeling it I
mean she's your mom you know she's your
mom so you know I mean what she feels
and so yeah so that's you know the last
thing to go and another thing that's
very interesting
and then I didn't know this is that you
can go like 15 days with no food or
water
cuz pretty much what happens is when
you're dying like in your you know like
my mom's throat started to you know kind
of choke you know
tighten up you can't eat and if you
can't eat you can't live and if you
can't drink water you can't live so what
happens is is the reason why you know
she could live so many days without food
or water
is because your body starts eating your
body so the problem fats start feeding
off of each other that's why you see
people like in the Jewish kind of uh or
is it the Holocaust you know where the
people don't eat for so long and it's
just their bodies eating their body so
it's it's feeding itself I didn't know
that no I know is that wild crazy
yeah I heard only a few days without
water Phil I know you can go but you're
you're literally lying there you can't
like live with all that and walk around
right right you can't let you expend any
energy no you're just lying there and my
dad - you know my dad you know you you
just need to stop eating and drinking
and then you know and then obviously I'm
freaking out going because because I
think it's torture yeah yeah where the
[ __ ] is the morphine this isn't [ __ ]
cool yeah you know but they're like and
then they say they say no no there okay
there okay there okay and I'm like
really they don't seem okay and they
know that they're okay that's what they
say yeah I know and then also my mom I
said to my mom how do you know it's
enough and then they said when she
starts tearing that's when she's in pain
you know when she starts tearing and
that's when you give just a little bit
of morphine you know huh it's [ __ ]
crazy dude yeah if I were you guys I get
someone that does hospice you know dr.
Joe we have a doctor brave yeah but no
he works that's where he works that's
what he does yeah that's [ __ ] cuz
because I think educating people you
know cuz everyday people need to really
know what they're [ __ ] getting into
right cuz it's [ __ ] scary dude and
I'd imagine like psychologically
everything is processed everything yeah
it's [ __ ] gnarly would you walk in
and see people that like oh that bed is
empty and she was here yesterday would
you walk no she was in the house but
both my parents died in their home okay
you know in their homes but under
hospice care under hospice care yeah but
it's just [ __ ] up dude yeah man it
seems like you don't think yeah what do
you think is better having experienced
it do you think that if it just goes
like that and you weren't prepared for
it and the person's just gone or do you
think having this kind of slow drawn-out
process what you just said the first one
yeah yeah unless you had unresolved
stuff like something you needed to fix
that you could have fixed and you didn't
then then it's like then you get the
regret
but it's yeah that's true but you can
fix it in 10 minutes and then you still
got all this hospice care to deal with
yeah you know it's just yeah it always
seems like I mean the likeness of
hospice and death and funerals is a
crazy business it's again in the funeral
business you know and then oh also
another thing is you know the guy that
came to pick up my mom and the stretcher
yeah and all that stuff that guy's just
like [ __ ] punching and punching out
right deal it's his gig yeah it's like
he's like the first thing he says
without being I sorry for your loss
anyways where is she I gotta go gotta
[ __ ] hate at [ __ ] 8 o'clock yeah
this is my only pick up today yeah yeah
it's and you're going like I don't know
if you guys know my life is shattered
right now this is everything yeah [ __ ]
dude and they come in they take her out
on a stretcher and yetti wrap it you
know your wrap you wrap and then they do
a stretcher and they put it in and you
shut the door and [ __ ] goes to the
funeral the funeral parlor and then
eventually in the next 2 or 3 days you
go there and if you want to view the
body were you in the room when she died
are you in the house or did you come
over after no it was it was basically I
knew she was gonna die cuz it been like
14 days that she hadn't eaten and it was
a night before you know we had Chinese
food not obviously me and my mom but my
my mom's caregiver and my brother and um
and I kind of knew you know what I mean
so then I woke up to like text messages
from I guess it was TMZ cuz they [ __ ]
knew before I [ __ ] knew I mean they
get paid by these guys who picked bodies
up and stuff like that were people that
you call this some of them probably
money from TMZ
yo so anyway whatever but I mean I knew
when she died I knew was gonna be a big
deal of course because of her pass and
what she had done yeah I wasn't really
surprised but it was heavy to see all
the outpour and you know I got like
flowers from dr. dre like he sent me
like his him and his wife sent me like a
whole thing Wow it was just like you
know random Quincy Jones sent me stuff
and I think you know it's gonna be a big
deal but you I mean the amount the
amount of people and who they were and
their mom was really you know I mean
because of what my mom did and how she
treated comedians and and you know back
in you know in the 70s 80s and 90s she
was
you know the den mother and and she um
she cared you know in the comics knew
she cared you know that's why you know
these guys were homeless pretty much you
know they're all [ __ ] homeless mm-hmm
and she took him you know she took care
of him is that was that with the
location it's had now is that the
original location or of the store annot
yeah it was never anywhere before that
no it was first it was the original room
which was just a small room and then it
started to do well and then they knocked
the wall down she bought the other part
of the building which used to be C rows
and then she took over the belly room
upstairs so then it you know she took
the whole thing over yeah and then it
became I mean the comedy store now it's
it's still like the club in LA yeah I
mean it's there's always activity in
front of ya behind it it's all comic
spot well how do you feel about the
Showtime show that they're doing or that
they did that one asked me about this
like loosely based you know it's kind of
sensitive the whole thing to wait for me
the whole thing that went down I thought
the way Jim Carrey kind of organized
that I don't think was cool you know I
mean he didn't ask us hey you gotta went
around do this yeah is he using the name
of the club no like we legally went
around it you know it means clearly that
story and there's a character that's
just like your whatever dude it's like
you know who cares you know it's like
yeah we're like you know the ten
documentaries on the Rolling Stones and
it's like people are like oh that Mick
Jagger all that wasn't done it was like
who cares right it's like if Jim wanted
to do it let him do it like [ __ ] it
would you have been involved if they
asked you if it was about the Comedy
Store and it was more specific but I'll
do my own show about it I you know in my
own documentary my own book my own thing
about it cuz it's through my eyes I'm
the one that saw it all and that's why I
said [ __ ] see it right and and it's
also one of those things that people are
never gonna get tired of those stories
mm-hmm yeah cuz you so many tense
stories on the comedy store from
different angles yeah yeah it's like who
cares have you read a book about it
already no no I'm in the process of
doing doing it right now
so how's Paul Muni I haven't seen or
heard from him if I talked to Greg over
at Caroline's in
he says that you know and I've you know
reached out through different people I
don't think he's doing too well
I don't know where he's at okay in
Oakland I don't know I also don't know I
haven't I haven't heard anything yeah
how about Brian Holtzman was always a
really funny guy to the gwantak comedy
strong kind of close the shows yeah I
don't think people here in New York
really know him but he's pretty
legendary he's still working there yeah
he is yeah he's our friend
yeah yeah he's really [ __ ] funny guy
yeah he's really funny I did press this
week though I was in Columbus and the
guy was like staring the morning radio
god no I love Columbus but I hate to
impress I mean it's worse different it's
New York yeah this isn't you know this
is more yeah and we know each other it's
where were you going someplace you don't
know the pair oh you've met them once
and yeah hey didn't I call you to do my
movie you did but I couldn't say I
always call him cuz I want to work with
him I've never worked with him before
and I think it'd be funny yeah yeah I
could put the shooting why don't you
what you call polybag we talk we talk
with the shoot day I don't remember it
was guest house yeah but you needed a
bunch of dates and there was a good
amount I wasn't available I said do you
need just a couple I think you said you
needed it straight through it was just
of the nation though you would have been
funny it was uh I did a movie called
guest house where I played this guy that
won't leave out of a guest house I got
all these comedians and Eric Griffin
Zinat Bobby Lee's in it I would love to
do in and you know a lot of great comics
are in it and I always want to work with
him because I think we'd be funny on the
camera yeah I think it'd be gravy funny
yeah I would love to do it man so thing
else comes up please hey when you
started gaining a reputation for all the
beautiful women that you were betting on
a fairly regular basis I'm not Jewish
those Harris yeah the people what's your
story cuz you're pretty cool what's your
story I do this yeah I do radio were you
here with the Opie and Anthony I was he
was an intern who usurped the boss's ID
throne yet oh you D throw him the boss I
did yeah yeah throughout trick I
remember those guys yeah I'm backstage
shenanigans yes right you guys are still
friendly or not we don't all beer I'm
gonna talk but die Anthony I talk you
know twice a week am I allowed to say hi
to him is he cool yes Anthony what's up
it's Pauly Shore let me do your podcast
in your house
in your house come over your house no I
can hang out with them what about Opie
dude another thing I was doing a podcast
yo I'll do your podcast in your house
you'll just show up at the house and do
it you don't care yeah good for you yeah
right so so you're starting to develop a
reputation for having many many
different girlfriends you know what I
mean at the same time you're doing
comedies that are pitched as really
family comedies they're not adult
comedies was that ever a thing that
people would come to you and say hey you
got to start [ __ ] all these girls
because people are finding out and it's
hurting hurting box office that's a good
question does anyone not go see a movie
because the guy [ __ ] a lot of girls I
don't think it's a deterrent a family
I'm saying if you're doing a family
comedy and you're like oh that's the guy
who like [ __ ] in the grotto at the
Playboy Mansion all the time I keep
hearing that don't first of all but
maybe I know we used to have fun up
there that's what it was we went oh no
you weren't with me I went with big a
but we went and I saw the game room it
was it was like a publicity party thing
yeah but there's like sex rooms in the
Arcadia room did you have sex in the
arcade room with and say okay you want
to approach this girls all over I mean
do you just approach really any other
girl or do they approach you they
approached me mostly you know I mean the
thing is it's like let's let's cut to
the chase the Playboy Mansion was a
place for women to meet celebrities
right I mean Hefner all his friends were
celebrities and that's kind of what it
was so he would he invited me up there
many years ago and I was kind of like
one of his friends mm-hmm and so I would
be up there and you know and I would
just meet girls they would just you know
there was two parties a year there was
the Midsummer's party and then there was
like the Halloween party and those are
the two big parties and basically women
would come from all over America and
they would go to LA for that weekend and
they would go up there and they'd meet
celebrities and have sex with them
sometimes sometimes not if they wanted
to
yeah I don't know was it weird though if
you were talking to a girl who was hot
and you liked her and then a bigger
celebrity came over said that must have
happened it's a bummer yeah yeah like
Bill Maher and like Jesus Christ it's
almost you know it is I kind of the word
of its there's not a word called
equivalent is there a word you could say
okay wait equivalent it's like Vegas you
know you go to Venice and like people's
ambitions are like down there down I
think their inhibitions yeah you know
they're kind of like damn like oh it's
Vegas it happens in Vegas stays it you
know the same thing I see it's the same
exact kind of mentality it's the Playboy
it doesn't count here exactly
people have to check their phones though
once phones became a thing with cameras
uh I think it all started kinda I mean
it was like he didn't want pictures
taken you know because he had his own
photographer right you know his own
photographer but um so how did it work
though I mean and I'm only asking
because it's the only I remember the
room so well take the small little house
thing the art the game room and it's got
like all these great video games in it
right like arcade games like old school
and it's like oh that's so cool you come
in here and play all the video games you
want but then there was like two rooms
yes that you would open the door and the
whole floor is a mattress yeah that's
all it is
it's covered with covered in carpet yeah
and like velvet yeah and then there's
like mirrors and stuff around and I'm
like oh my god there's like sex rooms in
the game room you think there's a lot of
loads dropped in that room so many
Pauly's is what I think yeah here's what
I think so Hugh Hefner died and before
he died he put all his tapes there was
all the the tapes in the ocean yeah
right cuz he would record a lot of stuff
right it's your guy can you look at that
online yeah Troy can over in I remember
yeah but that story this age right here
he somebody he knew who he trusted took
it out to the ocean and dropped it do
you think he was filming everybody or
just himself I think everybody but they
they're being filmed or no there it is
look at Hugh Hefner dumps casket of sex
tapes into the sea hilarious so you
think
maybe he had cameras set up in all these
little rooms well he did that for
several reasons
uh-huh because of shenanigans what if
something bad happened that's true
somebody yeah somebody says a hotel if
you go to a nice hotel there's cameras
everywhere
well his house is a house that's open to
the public why wouldn't he have cameras
that's true and things go wrong and one
of those you know
yeah wrong so so at the end of the day I
think that was very classy of him yeah
then he was recording it and then he got
rid of everything it's not even like
after I died it's all yours it's no
after I die it dies with me correct
yeah well that was really classy oh
because I assumed there probably would
have been what I mean we sex tapes oh
yeah we want to invest in scuba diving
gear other people yeah I mean just the
amount of it you know it's a private
thing but again I think the main reason
why he probably had that was in case
something bad happened yeah yeah in case
anybody said something happened that
didn't happen you know he might have
some proof I wonder how much that was
other people and how much those tapes
were just him most them were just him
camera setup [ __ ] baby keep them in the
house no so no one can get to him like
you know you must be probably had a
whole way I mean first of all like when
you when I went there for that party
nobody was allowed in the house by that
point so like you know I think that
there were definitely parts of that
house that people did not have access to
yeah right yeah yeah yeah big parties
the house was open but you can go up to
his bedroom right but it was such a
great it was it was I went all the time
you know I mean people would be like why
do you go up there so much I'm like
because this is gonna end
mmm right and right this isn't gonna go
on forever and there's nothing and ever
be like this ever
and I'm his guest yeah I wanna go and
enjoy it
did you ever going nothing was happening
like where there's just nothing going on
there was always a little something well
I wouldn't go up there if there's
nothing happening just say hey would you
just show up or would you know there'd
be like you know they'd have Sunday fun
days or they would have you know they
would have like
pool parties they would do you know
what's the funniest was the Easter egg
hunt that was like a big thing for him
like because all the bunnies there like
Easter they loved that they put their
dresses on you know I mean you could
always have animals and kids and
families it's just so funny we do all
this like little kids stuff but then you
know once it all before yeah then there
beetle but that's the same thing as the
Comedy Store it was no different
mhmmm it's the same thing it's like you
got all this comedy and then and then
you know at houses people are [ __ ]
and doing drugs it's right I mean Robin
Williams was wild right you know yes
your see Robin under the influence yeah
he was always you know partying and
having fun and you know living that life
you know but that's such a healthy
attitude to have that early that you
were like this is going to end this is
not because I think so many people in
that position especially when they're
young are going this is reality this is
what life is like now this is forever
and you're like nope this is just gonna
yeah no that's yeah you know but um I'm
happy you know I'm okay you know after
this whole thing that I've been through
whatever it is like so well good he
lived a life man I've seen it and you've
lived a life
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM f
[Music]